>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
IF YOU LIVED IN THIS COUNTRY 15
YEARS AGO AND YOU'VE GOT A GOOD
MEMORY YOU MAY REMEMBER THE
CREATION OF SOMETHING CALLED THE
NATIONAL SECURITY DIVISION AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IT WAS CREATED BACK IN 2005 WHEN
THEY RE-UPPED THE PATRIOT ACT.
NOW THE POINT OF THE NATIONAL
SECURITY DIVISION, WE WERE TOLD
AT THAT TIME, WAS TO CONDUCT
"COUNTERTERRORISM AND COUNTER
ESPIONAGE OPERATIONS AGAINST
FOREIGN ADVERSARIES."
THIS WAS THE BIG STUFF.
MOSTLY IT WAS ISLAMIC TERROR,
WHICH WAS THE PRIMARY THREAT OF
THAT TIME, BUT THESE WERE ALSO
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF BUSTING
CHINESE SPIES WHO WERE TRYING TO
STEAL OUR NUCLEAR SECRETS,
STOPPING SUICIDE BOMBERS AND
HIJACKERS.
NOT SMALL STUFF, CRIMES THAT
THREATENED THE NATION BEER THAT
WAS THEN.
THEN JOE BIDEN BECAME PRESIDENT
IN JANUARY, AND THE ENTIRE
MISSION OF THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT CHANGED AND TURNED
INWARD AGAINST YOU.
A FEW DAYS AGO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE UNDER THE RADICAL
ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK GARLAND
ANNOUNCED THAT THE NATIONAL
SECURITY DIVISION HAS A NEW
DOMESTIC COMMISSION.
ACCORDING TO GARLAND, EFFECTIVE
IMMEDIATELY THE NATIONAL
SECURITY DIVISION IS HANDLING
THE INVESTIGATION OF
"HARASSMENT, INTIMIDATION, AND
THREATS OF VIOLENCE AGAINST
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS, TEACHERS,
WORKERS IN OUR NATION'S PUBLIC
SCHOOLS."
THE QUESTION IS, WHO IS
THREATENING THESE TEACHERS AND
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS?
IS IT AL QAEDA?
IS IT THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT?
IS IT ISIS-K?
NO, IT IS PARENTS.
PARENTS ARE ANGRY ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN SCHOOLS.
WHERE THE ANGRY?
TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT THE PEOPLE
JOE BIDEN HAVE NOMINATED TO
SENIOR LEADERSHIP POSITIONS IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
TAKE A LOOK AT YOUTUBE VIDEOS,
WHILE THEY STILL EXIST, OF WHO
BOARD MEETINGS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND YOU WILL KNOW
EXACTLY WHY PARENTS ARE MAD.
PARENTS WHO BELIEVE IN THINGS
LIKE BIOLOGICAL -- TEACHING
KIDS TO HATE THEIR PARENTS,
THOSE ARE THE THREAT, ACCORDING
TO THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
YOU WILL NOTICE IF YOU LOOK
CLOSELY THAT NOWHERE IN
MERRICK GARLAND'S RECENT ORDER
OR THE DOJ POSITIVIST PRESS
RELEASE IS AN EXPLANATION OF
THESE "THREATS OF VIOLENCE."
WHAT THREATS OF VIOLENCE?
BECAUSE VIOLENCE OCCURRED AT
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS?
NO.
LOOK CLOSER AND YOU WILL FIND
THIS ONE, "THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WILL ALSO CREATE
SPECIALIZED TRAINING AND
GUIDANCE THAT WILL HELP SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS UNDERSTAND THE
TYPE OF BEHAVIOR THAT
CONSTITUTES THREATS.
OH, SO IT IS A PROPAGANDA
OPERATION FUNDED BY YOU OUT OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF SO-CALLED
JUSTICE DESIGNED TO TELL
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS THAT WHEN PARENTS
COMPLAIN IT IS DOMESTIC
TERRORISM, NOT THE FIRST
AMENDMENT, NOT YOUR CONSTITUENTS
VOICING LEGITIMATE COMPLAINTS.
IT IS EFFECTIVELY A FOREIGN
ADVERSARY TRYING TO KILL YOU.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
TRYING TO CONVINCE SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS USING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THAT THEY ARE IN
PHYSICAL DANGER FROM PARENTS AND
THOSE PARENTS ARE NATIONAL
SECURITY THREATS.
ONCE AGAIN, NOTHING LIKE THIS
HAS EVER HAPPENED IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THIS IS AN UTTER PERVERSION OF
THE MISSION AND THE POWER OF THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
IT IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO
OVERSTATE HOW SINISTER AND CRAZY
THIS IS.
WE ALMOST NEVER PLAY THE
EQUIVALENCE GAME BECAUSE IT IS
TIRESOME AND IN THIS CASE, IT IS
HARD TO RESIST.
IMAGINE IF DONALD TRUMP DOJ
DESIGNATED, SAY, CNN ANCHORS AS
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
PUT IT IN WRITING AND THEN TOLD
MEN WITH GUNS TO ENFORCE THE
LAW.
HOW WOULD THAT GO OVER?
WE, FOR ONE, WOULD BE OUTRAGED
BY THAT.
ALL DECENT AMERICANS WOULD.
A LOT OF CNN ANCHORS MADE
EXCUSES FOR VIOLENCE DURING THE
RIOTS OF LAST YEAR, BUT THE
MEDIA AREN'T UPSET ABOUT THIS.
WHEN POWERLESS SUBURBAN PARENTS
RESIST HAVING NIHILISTIC RULING
CLASS IDEOLOGIES IMPOSED BY
FORCE ON THEIR CHILDREN, OUR
MEDIA SEEM TO BELIEVE IT IS
PERFECTLY FINE TO DESIGNATE THEM
TERRORISTS AND THREATEN THEM
WITH FIREARMS.
>> AND A VERSION OF AMERICA
WHERE SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS HAVE
BECOME THE NEW CULTURE WERE
BATTLEGROUNDS WITH CHILDREN
CAUGHT IN THE CROSS HAIRS.
SOMETIMES LITERALLY AND
SOMETIMES FIGURATIVELY.
>> RIGHT NOW EVERYONE FROM THE
PROUD BOYS TO CUE IN ON
INFLUENCERS ARE TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE THEIR MEMBERS,
THEIR FOLLOWERS, THEIR MANIACS
TO SHOW UP AT SCHOOL BOARD MEET.
>> SOME BEHAVIORS SO BAD IT IS
BEING COMPARED TO DOMESTIC
TERRORISM.
>> THIS BECOMES A NATION ALL
SECURITY CRISIS.
>> PRETENDING SCHOOL BOARD
HARASSMENT AND INTIMIDATION
AREN'T OFF THE CHARTS.
>> SIMILAR TACTICS TO WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6TH THAT ARE
NOW BEING TURNED AGAINST SCHOOL
BOARDS NATIONWIDE IN A TREND
THAT IS REALLY DISTURBING AND
SINISTER.
>> CONSERVATIVES MANUFACTURE
OUTRAGE OF HER MASKS HISTORY
LESSONS, TOOK OUR SCHOOL BOARDS
HOSTAGE LIKE A BUNCH OF
SCREAMING MANIACS.
>> Tucker: THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS DESIGNATED
AMERICAN PARENTS WHO ARE UNHAPPY
WITH THE EDUCATION THEIR
CHILDREN ARE RECEIVING AS
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS, AND THE
MEDIA ARE DEFENDING IT.
THIS IS SO SHAMEFUL IT IS HARD
TO DESCRIBE.
THE ENTIRE POINT OF A FREE PRESS
IS TO PROTECT THE WEAK FROM THE
STRONG.
BUT AS USUAL AND MORE FLAGRANTLY
EVERY DAY, OUR MEDIA DOES
EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE.
THEY SLOBBER OVER BILLIONAIRES,
THEY DEFEND THE POWERFUL, THEY
CALL YOU A BIG IT YOU CHALLENGE
GEORGE SOROS, AND ON THE OTHER
HAND THEY CLAP LIKE SEALS AS A
WORKING GO TO JAIL FOR NOT
CRIMES.
THEY PRETEND THAT IS NOT WHAT
THEY ARE DOING, THAT THEY ARE
SUCKING UP TO POWER, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, BUT THEY ARE.
THEY ARE TELLING YOU THIS IS
ABOUT DOMESTIC TERRORISM, THEY
ARE REPEATING MERRICK GARLAND'S
OWN WORDS, FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
I MUSTN'T
I ON MSNBC, ONE OF THE BYADMINIS
PROMISED THAT SHE WOULD AIR
DEFINITIVE PROOF THAT PARENTS
WHO DARED TO CHALLENGE THE
ORTHODOXIES OF THE JOE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ARE IN FACT A
GRAVE THREAT TO NATIONAL
SECURITY.
SHE WOULD SHOW US PROOF THAT THE
NATIONAL SECURITY DIVISION NEEDS
TO INVESTIGATE THESE PARENTS,
TREAT THEM LIKE CRIMINALS FOR
DARING TO SPEAK UP AT THEIR OWN
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS BEFORE
MEMBER OF THE SCHOOL BOARD THEY
ELECTED TO RUN SCHOOLS THEY PAY
FOR TO EDUCATE THEIR CHILDREN.
HERE'S THE EVIDENCE SHE
PRESENTED.
>> I WANT TO PLACE MORE SOUND OF
THE SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS SO WE
CAN GET A SENSE OF HOW OUT OF
CONTROL SOME OF THEM ARE
GETTING.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> DON'T PUT MASKS ON OUR KIDS
ANYMORE BECAUSE I'M TELLING YOU
WHAT, I AM A MOM WHO IS FEARLESS
AND I WILL COME AFTER YOU!
>> YOU ARE ALLOWING CHILD ABUSE,
YOU ARE ALLOWING CHILD ABUSE,
YOU ARE ALLOWING CHILD ABUSE.
>> THINGS HAVE BECOME SO SCARY
THESE MEETINGS, THE
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING
SCHOOL BOARDS ARE ASKING FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO HELP, ARGUING THE
CLASSIFICATION OF THESE ACTIONS
COULD BE EQUIVALENT TO A FORM OF
DOMESTIC TERRORISM.
>> Tucker: SO MOTHERS STAND UP
BEFORE THEIR SCHOOL BOARD WHICH
IS THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS,
IN FACT THEIR DUTY AS PARENTS,
TO SAY THAT THEY BELIEVE BASED
ON A LOT OF SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
THAT THEIR CHILDREN ARE BEING
HURT BY A POLICY THAT MAKES NO
SENSE.
IMAGINE LOOKING AT THAT TAPE AND
BLAMING THE MOMS.
AND SUGGESTING THEIR BEHAVIOR IS
"SCARY."
AND THEY ARE TERRORISTS AND THE
FBI SHOULD SHOW UP AT THEIR
HOUSE AND HASSLE THEM LIKE THEY
ARE ISIS-K.
DON'T PUT MASKS ON OUR CHILDREN
ANYMORE, THAT IS CHILD ABUSE.
ACTUALLY, THAT IS TRUE AND
ANYONE WHO HAS LOOKED AT THE
DATA KNOWS IT IS TRUE.
BELGIAN PEDIATRICIANS IN THE
ACADEMY OF MEDICINE JUST ISSUED
THIS ASSESSMENT OF MASKS IN
SCHOOLS.
HERE IT IS, "TESTING CHILDREN,
IMPOSING MOUTH MASKS IN
QUARANTINE GO AGAINST THE
PRINCIPLE OF FIRST DO NO HARM
WHICH IS INCLUDED IN THE
HIPPOCRATIC OATH THAT DOCTORS
TAKE.
THESE DRASTIC ACTIONS DO MUCH
MORE DAMAGE TO CHILDREN IN THE
SHORT AND LONG TERM THEN GOING
THROUGH THE COVID INFECTION
ITSELF."
NOW THAT IS NOT SOME ANGRY MOM
FROM LAGUNA BEACH.
THOSE ARE PHYSICIANS SAYING THAT
AND IF YOU LOOK AROUND, AND YOU
SHOULD, YOU WILL NOT FIND A
SINGLE STUDY ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD THAT FUNDAMENTALLY
CONTRADICTS THAT ASSESSMENT.
THERE IS NO SCIENCE, NONE,
BEHIND THESE MASK MANDATES FOR
CHILDREN.
IN FACT, DAYS AGO MIGUEL
CARDONA, SECRETARY OF EDUCATION,
TRY TO CITE A STUDY -- AND WHEN
HE USED THIS STUDY TO JUSTIFY A
POLITICAL DECISION, THE SENIOR
AUTHOR OF THE STUDY SAID THAT HE
HAD NO IDEA WHAT HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT AND COMPLETELY
MISREPRESENTED HER RESEARCH,
WHICH BY THE WAY HAD NO CONTROL
GROUP, SO BY DEFINITION DOESN'T
PROVE ANYTHING.
BUT DON'T BOTHER, DON'T EVEN
BOTHER GETTING RATIONAL ON THIS
SUBJECT.
IF YOU DARE TO CITE SCIENTIFIC
CONCLUSIONS, YOU ARE A DOMESTIC
EXTREMIST IN THE MEDIA WILL
DEMAND YOU BE INVESTIGATED BY
THE FBI.
AND THEY ARE JUSTIFYING THIS IN
EXACTLY THE SAME WAY THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT EXPLAINS THE WAY
MURDERS ARE COMMITTED.
THEY ARE ACCUSING PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY WRONGED BY
THE GOVERNMENT OF UNDERMINING
DOMESTIC STABILITY BY
COMPLAINING ABOUT IT.
WHAT USED TO BE CALLED
LEGITIMATE CIVIC DISAGREEMENT IS
NOW A THREAT TO THE NATION.
>> IS THIS REALLY ABOUT PEOPLE
BEING UPSET ABOUT MASK MANDATES
OR ARE THERE UNDERLYING
DISRUPTIVE FORCES?
WHITE NATIONALISTS, ANARCHISTS,
WHATEVER IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
ARE USING MASK MANDATES IN A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS TO WAGE
CHAOS.
>> Tucker: GET THAT MORON OFF
TELEVISION, THAT IS HURTING OUR
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE RACIST NOW?
THEY ARE RACIST BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT THEIR KIDS TO BE
MASKED?
IMAGINE SAYING SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
THERE ARE UNDERLYING FORCES AT
WORK.
A SECRET FORCES YOU CAN'T SEE.
IT MUST BE QANON OR WHITE
SUPREMACISTS.
THERE ARE NO ORGANIZED WHITE
SUPREMACISTS IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PROBLEMS, THAT
IS NOT ONE OF THEM HERE THE
POINT IS WE DON'T LIKE THEIR
POLITICS THEREFORE THEY DON'T
DESERVE CIVIL LIBERTIES.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE SAYING,
THAT IS WHAT THEY BELIEVE.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER IF ANY OF
THESE PEOPLE HAVE EVER SEEN A
SCHOOL BOARD MEETING OR IF THEY
ARE REPEATING WHAT THEY WERE
TOLD.
THE PARENTS DIDN'T START CHAOS,
THEY DIDN'T START THIS, THEY
HAVE A TOTALLY ORDINARY AND
UNJUSTIFIED EDUCATION THAT THE
KIDS WOULD BE EDUCATED IS THAT
KIDS HAVE BEEN EDUCATED FOR MORE
THAN 100 YEARS IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
PARENTS SLOWLY WOKE UP TO THIS
FACT, THE KIDS ARE BEING TAUGHT
RACISM IN SCHOOLS, THEIR KIDS
ARE BEING HURT, WHAT THE HELL
ARE YOU DOING?
PARENTS GO TO MEETINGS TO VOICE
OBJECTIONS TO TEACHERS
ADVOCATING RACIAL SEGREGATION
AND BOOK BURNING AND THEY ARE
DOING IT ON CAMPUS, THEY ARE NOT
DOING IT IN SECRET, THESE ARE
JUST NORMAL AMERICANS.
HERE'S VIRGINIA BACK IN MAY.
>> IT'S FUNNY HOW THEY ARE SO
AFRAID OF THEIR CHILDREN SEEING
ANOTHER VIEW OF SEXUALITY,
GENDER OR RELIGION.
IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT BOOKS
THAT ARE ASSIGNED, LET'S READ
"TO KILL A MOCKINGBIRD"
TOGETHER.
IF YOU ARE NOT WILLING TO
CONSIDER THE RACIAL TRAUMA THIS
ASSIGNED BOOK CAUSES BLACK
CHILDREN WITH ITS WHITE
SAVIORISM, THEN YOU HAVE NO
BUSINESS DISCUSSING ANY BOOKS.
>> Tucker: WELL, EXACTLY.
IF YOU'RE TELLING KIDS THAT
DR. SEUSS AND "TO KILL A
MOCKINGBIRD," BOTH OF WHICH ARE
EXPLICITLY ANTIRACIST AND WERE
BEFORE THAT WAS EVEN A TERM
THOUGHT UP BY SOME GRIFTER AT
BOSTON UNIVERSITY, IF YOU REALLY
BELIEVE THAT YOU ARE A LUNATIC.
LET'S JUST SAY THAT OUT LOUD,
YOU'RE A LUNATIC.
IF YOU'RE COMPLAINING ABOUT IT
YOU ARE NOT THE ONE WAGING
CHAOS.
LOOK AROUND CABLE NEWS AND YOU
WON'T FIND ANYBODY EXPLAINING
WHAT IS ACTUALLY GOING ON.
INSTEAD YOU WILL FIND PEOPLE
LIKE NICOLE WALLACE BARKING
ABOUT HOW PEOPLE WHO DON'T AGREE
WITH HER DON'T DESERVE CIVIL
LIBERTIES.
WE ALMOST NEVER USE HER NAME ON
THE AIR.
NICOLE WALLACE IS THE PHYSICAL
EMBODIMENT OF VIRTUALLY
EVERYTHING THAT IS WRONG WITH
THIS COUNTRY.
SHE IS, IN A WORD, LOATHSOME.
LET'S BE COMPLETELY HONEST, IF
THEY WERE DECLARED PUBLICLY
NICOLE WALLACE WAS A TERRORIST
FOR HER POLITICAL OPINION WE
WOULD UNHESITATINGLY LEAP TO HER
DEFENSE WITH A MAXIMUM, WE WOULD
DO IT INSTANTLY AND WE WOULDN'T
STOP BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN CIVIL
LIBERTIES.
WOULD SHE DO THE SAME FOR US?
OF COURSE NOT.
IF THE ENTIRE STAFF OF THIS SHOW
WAS ARRESTED TOMORROW FOR OUR
BELIEFS, NICOLE WALLACE WOULD
CELEBRATE AND THAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE.
WE BELIEVE IN CIVIL LIBERTIES,
AND THEY DON'T.
HOW CAN YOU TELL?
HAS NICOLE WALLACE OR ANYONE
ELSE AT MSNBC SAID A SINGLE WORD
ABOUT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SPYING ON GOOGLE SEARCHES?
THAT IS HAPPENING.
COURT DOCUMENTS SHOWING THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN OBTAINING
SENSITIVE PRIVATE INFORMATION
FROM ANY AMERICAN WHO TYPED IN
CERTAIN KEYWORDS INTO A GOOGLE
SEARCH.
A MINNESOTA JUDGE FOR EXAMPLE
RECENTLY APPROVED A SECRET
WARRANT MAKING GOOGLE PROVIDE
TRACKING ANYONE WITHIN A RADIUS
OF A DINA MINNESOTA WHO SEARCHED
FOR A MISSING PERSON'S NAME.
IT IS HAPPENING AND NO ONE ON
TELEVISION AND EVEN MENTIONS IT
BECAUSE THEY THINK THEY DESERVE
IT BECAUSE THEY DON'T THINK YOU
HAVE CIVIL LIBERTIES BECAUSE
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN GOD
BECAUSE THEY DON'T THINK YOU GOT
THOSE RIGHTS FROM GOD.
THEY THINK YOU GOT THEM FROM THE
GOVERNMENT AND THEY CAN TAKE
THEM AWAY BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN
NAUGHTY.
GOOGLE HAS A LOT OF TRACKING
INFORMATION ON THEIR USERS
INCLUDING SEARCH HISTORY GOING
BACK DECADES.
THAT IS SOMETHING ON THE LEFT
YOU THINK THEY WOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
20 YEARS AGO THEY WOULD BE ALL
OVER IT.
PROVE ONCE AGAIN THE GOVERNMENT
HAS TOO MUCH SURVEILLANCE POWER
OVER AMERICAN CITIZENS AND THEY
ARE ABUSING THIS TO SPY ON
AMERICANS WHO HAVE DONE NOTHING
WRONG.
BUT NOT ONE OF THE NATIONAL
SECURITY EXPERTS SO CALLED ON
MSNBC OR CNN WILL EVEN MENTION
IT.
WHY IS THAT?
BECAUSE THEIR JOB ISN'T TO
PROTECT YOU OR CIVIL LIBERTIES
BUT TO PROTECT THE PARTY IN
POWER.
THAT COULD BE WHY THEY ARE NOT
TELLING YOU ANYTHING ABOUT
MERRICK GARLAND'S PERSONAL
STATE.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S PERSONAL
STATE IN PERSECUTING PEOPLE WHO
CHALLENGE THE INSANITY WE ARE
SEEING ON SCHOOL BOARDS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
IT TURNS OUT MERRICK GARLAND'S
DAUGHTER IS MARRIED TO A MAN WHO
IS THE COFOUNDER OF AN EDUCATION
SERVICE COMPANY CALLED PANORAMA
EDUCATION, WHICH YOU WILL NOT BE
SURPRISED TO LEARN PROVIDES
MATERIALS ON CRITICAL RACE
THEORY TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
INCLUDING DISMANTLING
"UNCONSCIOUS BIAS AND SYSTEMIC
RACISM IN SCHOOLS."
OH, SO THE THING THAT PARENTS
ARE COMPLAINING ABOUT IS THE
THING THAT MERRICK GARLAND'S
FAMILY IS GETTING RICH FROM.
TWO DAYS AGO MERRICK GARLAND
MADE IT A CRIME TO COMPLAIN
ABOUT THE BELIEFS THAT ARE
ENRICHING HIS FAMILY.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT THIS
SPECIFIC COMPANY HAS RAISED A
TON OF MONEY FOR
MARK ZUCKERBERG'S FOUNDATION.
FAIRFAX COUNTY PUBLIC SCHOOLS
JUST SIGNED A $1.08 CONTRACT TO
CONDUCT A MULTIYEAR SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL LEARNING SCREENER THAT
GIVES IT THE RIGHT TO COLLECT
"PSYCHOMETRICS" ON ITS SCHOOL'S
STUDENTS.
YOU WANT THEM COLLECTING
PSYCHOMETRICS ON YOUR KID?
WHAT IS A PSYCHOMETRIC ANYWAY?
THIS IS INSANE.
ASKING KIDS IF THEY ARE "SAD,"
OR GENDER FLUID.
THIS IS HORRIFYING, ALSO
POTENTIALLY ILLEGAL.
ACCORDING TO THE DOJ PODGE OF
HIS OWN CONFLICT OF INTEREST
POLICY RAISES SERIOUS ETHICAL
ISSUES BUT OF COURSE IT IS.
THE DOJ RULES REQUIRE EMPLOYEES
TO SEEK OFFICIAL GUIDANCE BEFORE
"PARTICIPATING IN ANY MANNER IN
WHICH HIS OR HER IMPARTIALITY
COULD BE QUESTIONED."
OH, THAT WOULD INCLUDE
SITUATIONS IN WHICH MATTERS CAN
AFFECT THE POTENTIAL INTEREST OF
A RELATIVE WITH WHICH THE DOJ
EMPLOYEE HAS A CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP.
THAT PROBABLY INCLUDES YOUR
DAUGHTER, MERRICK GARLAND.
DID YOU DO THAT?
YOU CAN BE SURE THAT NO ONE IS
INVESTIGATING THAT QUESTION
TONIGHT.
INSTEAD THEY ARE PROMISING TO GO